wie bleibt irgendwo dann wird es fertig
vor der soziale medien für ins gericht
wenn aber mal oben ohne mit nippel
sichtbar posiert wird das nicht gelöscht
und es geht aber der account janis nikos
und hat sie immer noch mal ein viertel
so ganz frei und nur den nippel struff
und beweisen
bevor er
musste ins tak analog lokführer kind
kardashian und ich mich sofort auffallen
dass mit nicht gesehen
60 das ist
ja das große werk recherchiere wenn wir
nicht das gleiche
[Musik]
ja heute sagen dass immer wieder fleisch
und bossard mit der badria und mit mir
das mal
live mit publikum und sogar noch mit dem
gast mit der lisa christ bühne poetin
moderatorin kabarettistin und autorin
großen applaus
ja die
habe ich mit der branche über influence
kräht und über das phänomen wird sich
selber als influenza in bezeichnet
also im momentan wird die mieter stars
bezeichnet
machen
[Musik]
mit eine unterwäsche label die schweiz
produziert und
in sachen
denn eigentlich verlinken
verlinken
sie weiß nicht was sie da muss ich hin
und her und sich mit also ehrlich gesagt
haben einfach keine lust hat so lassen
sich auf lange und
so fort
und dann wird die und also es ist jetzt
aber nicht festgelegt wenn oder wie oft
das ist muss man es einfach mal zum
kraft nicht mehr wann und wie oft es
muss ein lecker und sah das auch nicht
aber ja genau ist nicht es ist nur für
die bereiche wie cry sich aus so
sehr ist groß label see findet irgendwie
cool und ich habe mir
überhaupt
das
ja aber
ja ich erwarte mir auch irgendwie so ist
das für mich also nicht ja nicht ganz ab
ich muss auch sagen wie instagram die
volle kontrolle darüber wie inszeniere
ich werde positiv zeige wie für das sie
zeigen die noten von a ha ausschnitt
zeigen
und ja dass ich das komplett
kontrollieren ist eigentlich sogar nur
sich
die komplette kontrolle darüber was es
über micro 9 zumindest öffentlichkeit
gelangt
ohne den völligen überhaupt was machen
all so was was sportlich unterwegs
passieren es gibt ja mehrere
zum teil
befindet sich gerade in ihrer schön und
filzstiften wegen der positiven anteile
ist deswegen jahr politische message
ja also offene art immer posten es geht
um verschiedene varianten warum man das
macht sich auch bemühte griff beweggrund
und die danken sicher darf man auch
nicht
ignorieren dass es natürlich auch schön
ist wenn man ein kompliment bekommt also
ich mache es nicht in erster linie für
das aber wenn ihr wisst ihr
es glaubt nicht machen aber das ist
jetzt nicht bei instagram
bin ich weit wenn das kvk hat
sap von
fakten oder und natürlich ist es als
politisches will so baute frau und ich
sage das jetzt sage das ist über die
situation relativ
und selbst ein problem
genau und eine ganz schöne sache nichts
kampf wo andere leute mit scrum für heil
und bekomm ich tendenziell
wahrscheinlich mehr positiv
wenn es um instagram gratis
ja und das muss mir steht das ist ihre
position zu kommen gleichzeitig
natürlich auch als frau und ja also die
aufführung mit dem körper cadel evans
sobald du als frau die körper so
benötigt wie ein normaler wie es andere
benutzen und quasi die jfg saarlouis
heim so wird das extrem fest verurteilt
für die gesellschaft ich sehe das ganz
kurzen als auch lösungen an das was man
also wenn sie beispielsweise industrie
deshalb nachts model für
risiko hot dog verwendet
ja es wird das komische züge mit
nachrüst verkauf kommen also wirklich
aufregendes roth verleger keine
klassische alles wichtigen wir
mittendrin im alter mobil sein kampf zu
immer dir wie heißt die arme die wir im
roter unterwäsche von vorschlägt
horst s
und das ist ja aus wird vermacht hat mit
dem blieb bibel körper ist quasi die
grundschrift und twitter ich lieber
körperliches allgemeingut warum werde
ich mir zu hause an gestorben ich zeige
grad
doch
ich habe da schon mal bringt die
mittelhand und wasser
generationen frau sicher
generationenfrage jedes werte ganz heiß
ich glaube schon dass es eine
generationenfrage ist ganz anders um mit
mir grad mehrere generationen benutzt du
bist das ist ein super gute punkte aber
sein name habe ich diskutiere ich glaube
es hätte ob es tatsächlich hat sich das
verändert umgang mit dem körper und ich
bin sehr interessant oder du hast in
münster jahrgang den 80er jahren setzte
jahrgang meine vorstellungskraft und ich
bin
zweiter kannte ich sie also zwei jahre
vor der matur wo du oft wahlgruppe
schreien zu retten falls sie aber das
wird schwer die tochter sie
während schöne gute große bruder 15
große bilder
und vor der wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
eingenommen als lead forscher generation
aber ich werde es noch einmal wissen wie
diese generation oder auf mini
generation muss ich sagen dass ich nur
jünger nur genau aber 14 schnell was mit
dem körper bild was bestellen was ich
was hat sich verändert
damit um exhibitionismus jetzt nochmal
ja auch so ziemlich für immer das
ziemlich gut es ist jetzt ein mini
familie integrierte maßstab familie aber
der grundsatz prämie wieder zurück dass
man die generation gerät jetzt vor
frauen hauptsächlich vater mit dem
körper um gottes ist mir egal
ja war einfach nicht die gleiche
mechanismus gesetzt ist wenig und miss
große zum die spielwiese mit ihrem
körper oder auch mit ihrem ganzen körper
spricht mit ihnen über ihre körper
verfügt worden ist oder wir fest dass
sich getraut überhaupt euro mietzner
gesellschaft in der öffentlichkeit wie
wichtig das ewig stimmen ist die
generation vom niveau das sich selber
verarbeiten und zu mehr wo das
eigentlich überholt aber trotzdem immer
nur mit restriktionen also du darfst du
auch sagen was du denkst dass wir dort
wartet das das was du denkst aber 66
höflich und sagst du das ist eine gut
verträgliche aber da geht es super buch
von kirsten
christian christin sage es jetzt richtig
lustig süß heißt das buch und das tut
genau das thematisieren das eigentlich
traurig dass es gott eigentlich um die
generation also die wird ausgeschrieben
hätte ich 27 gehen sz journalist inn wo
genau das beschreibt und zeit wir sind
immer noch das frauenbild beförderung
französisch
spanisch freundliches und so weiter was
mich interessiert ich habe nicht
verstanden was hilft das arts kam zu
wenig passiert das ist eine jagd gemacht
zum beispiel mit behörden
es wird zum beispiel mit dem
kleingedruckten ja das ist hat ja die
wache genau aber es ist schlicht es
scheint irgendwie ist die nächste
provokation aber sie sehen wie
genau und ist also ich sage nur es hat
nicht jedes bild in der unterwäsche
message darüber hinaus dass sie denke
mit glück im spiel war und ich rede mit
dem onyx und ich finde das allein ist
bissig lovestory penny hat ein buch
geschrieben wenn ihr die frau am morgen
wurden wir aufwachen die spielglück und
so akzeptieren wie sie ist würde ganz
großer teil von der industrie einfach
verbrecher wo frauen modul fahrweise ist
der frauen zeige dass sie nicht gut
genug sie zum extrem verkaufen und das
ist
selbst allmächtigen
das ist ja es ist kritisch
[Musik]
das
ist schon
extrem gut
und dann erzählt bietet sich nicht
immer aber genau das war unser seit
langer zeit das hat mich immer ein
unglaublich dass ich dachte
großvater mit sie im großen buch kreist
meer schwimme und sie kann das nicht
schwimmen das zeigt mir nicht und das
ist gab es noch nie auf den punkt heute
immer noch so jetzt mit
paul klee und so weiter also doch schon
viele frauen
und auch entwickler oder autos gesehen
es ist schon lustig dass mit der wiese
haar ist auch im buch vor der schule wo
es um hexe gott also die unbesiegbaren
hexen die unbesiegbare machte frauen
gezeigt sie das graue haare frau aber
auch ohne sonne stereotyp haxe
hervorrief zu didi hat mit großen augen
und erwartung dass das ein bisschen
bedrohlich wirken also wieder abkanzelt
wird von der gesellschaft wobei ja
interessant ist das 16 historisch
gesehen meistens die weiße frau
macht
[Gelächter]
ich werde da wäre ein schritt weiter
denn plötzlich vom körper riss ein tor
und hatte körpers politikum und das
andere ist ein plus von seelisch also
instagram hersteller audi nie
ist eine depression so schwartz
zurzeit genau die zeit sehr viel und und
wetzlar hauptsache enttabuisiert wenn
ich dich richtig versteuert das tab und
apples jahren depressiv gefordert
sondern findet das zu porträtieren super
geste und klickt sieht die kids im vor
glaube das kann jeder nur für sich
selber beurteilen inwiefern ist das ein
exhibitionist muss durchgesprochen
die selbstinszenierung und
wie kommst du mit dem mit der ambivalenz
zwischen enttabuisierung & exhibition
also ich glaube man muss frau bewusst
also es geht der grund warum das nicht
machen und ich finde das völlig legitim
und die finden immer wo edward
entblößter sei das mache und es gibt
auch post vornehme sehr lange bereit uns
genau passte und in mitgemacht haben
aber was beim er nach dem schlag geht
das ist machen ist meistens nicht
das wiso für mich fühle warum mache ich
es wirklich und wenn es ich finde das
ist ein vorteil vom authentische
figur aber das ist ein vorteil wenn ich
ganz lange damit grunde hat er sie das
gefühl haben oder lang eine ganze ladung
klassischen teil der gesellschaft
akzeptiert wird und wenn die öffentlich
machen wird die geachtet oder
ausgeschlossen oder bitte zu
verdanken ist ein moment
mit 18 16 20 uhr
gegen gefunden hat wenn mir dann
bereitet herz wifu mir gehts man
geschlecht und eben zum spiel therapie
gegangen
so und so und du denkst du dich das ist
super aber auch findet alarmieren nicht
gut genug ich habe mit mir selber das
hat mir so
verstanden ist einfach das hat mir so er
hat wieder eingeführt und er hat mich
akzeptiert gefühlt und er hat mir nie zu
erleiden wir haben recht lang im lager
sehr allein gefühlt mit sehr schöne
sache und ich glaube das ist so
hauptmotivation zum seligen sache post
und sagen sie kämpfen nicht allein
von mir gott so und so das
gemeinschaftliche das ist schon dass wir
eigentlich mehr geatmet
haben noch mal zurück auf die
generationenfrage sich wirklich nur
einem fahrer kurz darüber geräte bis im
letzten januar dries geworden und durch
in texas gelegene schwierig gefunden
mein system rocker zum ersten mal der
runde geburtstag wurde mit 20 stunden
ist
wirklich harte zeit für mich ist die ski
waren schwieriger werde es für mich
jetzt gut
fertig ist also noch wenig im leben
wirklich so entscheiden kann mit 40 ganz
vieles entschädigt sie und für mich
jetzt das einfacher gemacht
ja sie auch ganz gut aber
ich glaube das wofür metris die
irgendwie so schwierig macht ist dass
man auf der eine sieht das anders
beurteilt vor opera grieskirchner er hat
das zumindest kam ist aber lang
petreski bestellen verheiratet und das
rind und sunny cani welle
ja immer dank die haben das ja mit ist
einfach den wissenden und das ist nicht
passiert und sie schicken wieso erst
crew sowie der jugend- und machen mit
dem studium und dann fangen vom
berufsleben ist immer so es ist so linie
und jetzt hat es fühlt sich des kindes
ist so einfach das großes feld durchaus
richtige go und nimmer seite dieses duo
und das hat vorher erzählt ohne sowie
sophie leitplanke und jetzt einfach so
hart gewesen
absolut ist spät es ist wie so
orientieren im großer fahrt vom
erwachsen sie jetzt bin ich es bis 560
passiert jetzt mit mir irgendwie
gleichzeitig frau ines
bis fünf satzgewinne zugleich stellt das
muss jetzt geht oder bringen
die achtzehnte zwischen ja
[Gelächter]
übertrieben
wie gehst du mit der sv sucht oben wovor
ich auf den sozialen medien also gott
wenn du sax buß probierst ich selber
ausprobiert bis irgendwie war und den
aufträgen an was passiert doch bereits
nach mekka vielleicht was macht das mit
dem wetter irgendwie dieselbe situation
authentisch sie die große frage aber
letztlich doch nicht egal ob eine
spurlos an tv resonanz
ja das stimmt natürlich probieren sie
fest es ist so dass man damit auf die
likes und so und wie für mich wie die
das glaubt dass läuft mehr verdienen wir
wie viel spaß man sich ein medium wie
instagram hätte algorithmus und man weiß
zum beispiel wenn ich zum beispiel
regelmäßig post aber nicht mehr sexy
poster wenn ich es willst du mich viel
besser aus es
nur meine post oder das video aus
besseren posten so und die märkte jetzt
so langsam bin ich so froh so danken die
das bin ich immer machen und dann immer
wieder denke ich so lisa durch job macht
das einfach als hobby für den schnitt
mit dem es ist wie ich probiere das
suchteam
doch nägel und klassische form von
marketing sales marketing oder fashion
joe roth du glaubst du forderst du
bühnenauftritte die bücher schreibst
dass du bieter kritiker das heißt du
musst sie werden und gefragt werden und
dann hilft das natürlich
definitiv glauben aber autos über kritik
vom publikum vergütung ist programm
gegen die politik von ihm ins profil
also das merkt man der altersdifferenz
verschiedene plattformen können zeigen
und verschiedene publikum
zum zusammenbringen das ist spannend
wenn denn der jugendpolitik
aber vielleicht noch mal zu der leiche
natürlich beeinflusst wie das aber die
probieren trotzdem es ist gut zu wissen
eines sohnes ist das mekka für rich mit
dem thema
mit mit um und nur unterhosen die
maschen habe ich nicht sehr viel besser
unterstützen wir überraschen doch es ist
ja klar weil sie sich absetzen
spannend ist das zum beispiel nackt
hatte ich war schon heftig sagt
wiemer
sexarbeiterin und wenn ich es mit poster
sexy bild in lotterie
denn es
hätte das mekka für rich und wird von
instagram mappus wenn aber um die sex
arbeiterinnen befindet durchschnitt
steht angeblich körper beherrschen oder
nicht mega groß wenn das
sexarbeiterinnen machen denn er wieder
zensiert irgendwie merken muss das ist
es auch was man für wörterbuch zum
beispiel weil man darf nämlich bei und 6
arbeiter prostitution oder so aus aber
da muss man immer nur so und
würden damit dass der algorithmus mit
kallas und
es ist wirklich so dass zum beispiel
sechs arbeiten instagram mit extrem
restriktionen
extrem für verlauf aber wieder gelöscht
da kriegst so und de facto ist es
einfach nur
bei mir genau gleich ist nur mehr mache
ich so eine andere und es ist ja wieso
ich finde das sehr ich glaube dass
kanada ist general es
nicht bleiben wenn man irgendwo dann
wird es völlig von der sozialen medien
für instagram gericht wenn aber mal oben
ohne mit nippel sichtbar posiert wird
das nicht gelöscht und es geht aber der
account schöneres und wird sie immer nur
viertel zugangsknoten ist
richtig
schön werden bevor
noch rutschte ins tak analog zu dem kind
kardashian und ich mich sofort auffallen
dass mitnichten
xc60 muss aber das
wird ja das muss mir wegretuschieren
wenn wir nicht was das ist
noch mal zurück zu dem like sie wo und
wie viel man sieht es geht ein postamt
hat wo du es für noch darüber schrieb
wie das für dich ist dass es dich mein
geschah forscher suchen trost oder
erwartet dass man sich aber immer muss
verkaufen und dass du immer wieder muss
sagen heimat das programm gelungen doch
jetzt bitte ich
bis so toll lobte mechanisches buch
geschrieben gott ist das toll und so
finden
sich beherrschte
das geschehen wirklich extrem gar nicht
fragen ghostwriter aber das ist doch
halb ist daran ist wirklich immer so
viel das ist das immanuel kant krieg
oder mit mir tut sagt ein anderes klima
das ist es was macht tragen immer
garnier
hat taugt das mini sache wohn ich mache
für sich sprechen also das buch
verlassen und dann bis februar oder sehr
gut findet dass apple mit programmen
kachel und ostalb ist das mini
grundschulreform medium das auch immer
gesagt dass ich rot berührt und nicht
unbedingt ich als person vegas person
wie einfache person nicht besonders
anstrengend das ist nur schwer
vermarkten
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem ist ja
alles wenig machen mit mir verbunden
von dem hat schnittstelle das ist auch
okay aber das ist sowieso
megacool wird das stimmt einfach nicht
wir machen einfach und direkt an das
mittel nach und stehen in ihrer züge
sind hat in ihm einige hat zum teil oder
den sich hinter die befindlichkeit und
so
dass ich unbedingt bis materielles ja
aber im moment ist das material sind
momentan mit ihren schals
und jetzt ahne ist days of peace
die je nach der konstruktive sex kranker
hier was ich das für den schauer wieso
vergisst und schauer bis
mitte juni aber das hat mir nichts
anhaben
es ist die idee entstanden wirklich hat
das tatsächlich bei anderem zum mega
cool ich als produziert und
der texter soft und laboriert immer
wieder fit und ich finde die botschaft
sehr schön und wichtig
richtig und
illustration gemacht
bis
23 mit
und jörg van der heyden oder schauen
gespannt schauen bis morgen zusammen mit
dem slogan finde wie es passt meter groß
schlank überbezugs vor dem showdown
alexander schaf oder andere person
gefunden und dann haben wir uns
zusammengesetzt und so ist design
gemacht samen und das ja
sagen aber er ist viel
und
für ihre idee zum schau einfach schlägt
als machen natürlich noch ganz andere
lied auf so verschoss
das ist eine botschaft
da ist so oft das was was meinst du mit
ja also im text gott darum dass man
innere welt habe woher die also so eine
eigenschaft wo herr chi und möglichst
das pokerface h und sich selber geld und
als frau ermögliche attribut übernahm
und sich irgendwie witzig zeigen und auf
dem weg zum erfolg juni gegen wir
rücksicht auf andere das mega honoriert
wird und das ist
mein tag das ist beschrieb
freundlichkeit ideal ist
nur dass man immer nur da wo man
anstrebe selbst frau aber das ist doch
jetzt mehr interessant ist natürlich
darf in
offenburg radikale zärtlichkeit wo in
deutschland ein riesenhype dom ist wo
genau die these dass die genannte danke
brenders buch für das weniger fleisch
bürger über sensibel und die idee
eigentlich sind alle viel zuwachs 14 742
brachten den tränen
stimmt das wirklich partitionen
nicht dass sie ohne
also ob die aktuell ist für einsteiger
ist das nicht unterschrieb was es geht
ja schon so trennte gesellschafter des
sagen dass zumindest er wie zum beispiel
svenja flaßpöhler dass man zu
empfindlich wurden sind zusammenzucken
wenn die kritik und das wahnsinnig
persönlich und blogger denn als
empathischer sagen denn
halten
sondern wir sagen
man muss immer ich botschaften sage ich
fühle mich verletzt von einem rucksack
gesellschaft sowie nichts aber das aber
dass längst nicht alle lied aus der
mehrheitsgesellschaft macht das nicht
also das ist einfach nicht was macht mir
mut diese vorbilder lisa
was einfach die die sensibilität omen
ist zum sagen es war nicht einfach aber
sie macht einfach
aussah die ganze zeit und nicht auf
andere
absolute meine ich finde das ja nicht
dass man zu saft sind aber ich finde es
interessant dass ich glaube es gibt auch
eine gegenbewegung wo es auch eine
krippe wobei ich glaube es gar kein
mittel um das noch zu saft sind sondern
mangels zu narzisstisch und zu sehr um
ausreise stimmt und ich glaube die welt
gewinnt schnell sage bakterie botschaft
ich glaube es geht weg
gesellschaftlicher ebene wo du jetzt
angesprochen hätte herr schmidt der
musik empfindlichen twitter und es geht
die persönliche ebene und ich glaube
dass dies oft
von person zu person sehr persönlich
gemeint gegenüber für mich selber
bewegen verletzt wurde bei dem
horrorunfall
und die ab und zu wird jetzt checken und
die arbeitsmoral aber man braucht
meistens nicht so dick wie es aufgebaut
und mein kontakt nur möglich wenn man
die mode öffnet
sich eigentlich philosophisch sind man
den bremern uhr wiener zeit nicht
wundern und wenn du mich wunder zeigt
ständig begann ich möglichst
oft mit emanuel das ist doch schluss
[Applaus]
ja wie stören der zoo selbst endlich
oder ins visier ich eben sozial nicht
welche das ist doch momentan mit ihren
gern mit und werden für bronze abonniert
der kanal